[Music]
and you got yoga to be kidding me news
you got to yoga be kidding me y'all got
to be kidding me
news y'all got to be able to uh yeah you
got to be kidding me
it's weird English yeah submitted by
hipster yogi an extreme yoga pose sent a
woman to the hospital with stroke oh and
some blood rushed to her head this one's
kind of crazy yeah so is it Rebecca
Leigh I don't know what it's called
drummer stroke maybe she says it in here
because they have all these crazy names
but it's a family a headstand
she was doing a headstand and she she's
40 right now she still suffers from
memory loss headaches and pain in her
neck because of this one incident where
she did a headstand and she had done
thousands of head stands before us so
she didn't even it's a heads think about
it yeah I'll show you what it looks like
when they're [ __ ] doing Lotus [ __ ]
hands and [ __ ] and and they're just on
their head
no okay it was like this okay so she did
this before I met you no she didn't so
she she had done this thousands of times
before is that her yeah that's her like
that because I'm like oh she's 40
something killed yeah Rebecca is killing
the game this isn't when she was 40 this
is but this was just a few years ago
that's still good yeah show them that
pic with the other picture there's a lot
of [ __ ] 20 year olds that look like
theirs yeah this is also hurt
[Applause]
oh my god dude hey her pants are all the
way up to her [ __ ] heels dude I yeah
that's her and her husband she's Mary oh
yeah this is her in the hospital after
she what poses what the hell so it
changed her hair color that's crazy
yeah that's roots David um did she get a
stroke from the yoga pose or she was
just get her up she happened to be in a
yoga pose when it happened that's a
great question yeah so no it happened
from the yoga pose no way yeah and it
doesn't happen to very many people it's
very rare which is why she didn't even
think can we go back and can someone
define exactly what a stroke is so after
she finished the movement she felt
really happy about that she felt
refreshed after doing yoga but then
quickly her vision went blurry and her
left arm would uncontrollably flop
around when she tried to put her hair
into a ponytail
[Laughter]
is it a blocked vessel in the brain and
it knew like so basically I'll be good
at first let me just walk you through
what happened so she initially dismissed
her loss of vision and control in her
left arm she's like it's probably
because the slipped disc in my neck cuz
she already had that she goes yoga it's
[ __ ] up that's what she thought whoa
it was only to date it was so 2 full
days later two full days she looked at
in the mirror and she thought her pupils
looks weird so she's like oh no my eyes
look weird I think there's something
wrong so she had hurt her artist though
through a mission yeah so she had her
husband a driver to the hospital and the
the hospital the neurological intensive
care unit spent five days trying to
determine how she could have had a
stroke even though she exercised eat ate
healthy and didn't smoke
does yoga yeah and does yoga so she did
a lot of blood work ultrasounds MRIs CT
scans and then finally one of the CT
scans explained it basically her her
carotid artery one of four responsible
for delivering blood into your brain had
torn while doing the handstands
so the tear had sent blood a blood clot
into her brain and cause a stroke it
also caused a small bulging aneurysm to
develop she could have died how did she
pop this B maybe when she was having sex
with her husband her husband choked her
too hard you how to just pop a carotid
artery that's crazy I don't really I
don't know it's I don't think his
arteries you have oh yeah it torn yeah
it's so thick though huh so apparently
they say it's like during so the during
that pose I showed you when her hip
dipped a little bit I guess it like just
strange her neck in a weird way like
tore an artery I mean she sucks at yoga
did like no joke like that mean she
sucks she did yeah she might have done
the position like a face on Instagram
like she's killing a yoga game practice
not a perfect thing if you can do the
splits like [ __ ] I do yoga I do do
you're like no way yeah like not on the
bed she's like you know yeah you ever do
yoga yeah she's oh that's vertical
[ __ ] right there yeah vertical
[ __ ] follow a few yoga chelsye
conscious you see her do it Freddie
she's a pretzel for study purposes Donny
Berger's I do yoga yes I don't do these
crazy poses though I know I tripped out
of some of the yoga people because they
do some crazy [ __ ] like always wonder
what it looks like when they're naked no
you just go hot yogurt I see them all
practically naked yeah like the
difference remaking them having a
millimeter of clothing on your body
not much although one time nothing I was
in hot hot yoga class and Colin Farrell
was in my class with me and then
happened about three times do you try to
look out his dick no but all of the
girls were like huddled around him and
you were these tiniest shorts and he had
this like man bun and it was all buff
and stuff call the girl looks like he
has like a new strain of AIDS though
like you look damn that's [ __ ] up that
looks like you [ __ ] around too much
yeah I have I'll saw a sex tape terrible
oh I haven't yeah
this is because it was cold federal like
it was on my computer was it without you
got a guys sex I've never sought it up
but seek it out this year
call Farrell huh that you're very very
nice guy a party what a few time you
didn't bully my brother Dean and we
party together a few times he's sweet
dude he seems really nice he was talking
all the girls after all these like
housewife mom ladies were like that he's
charming and cool it's like it's so
really so nice I believe he was having
sex on a balcony or something oh I can't
remember too much that's pretty hot oh
he would never let's see it's good to
know but look it's good to know cuz
sometimes when I'm in yoga class unless
he's a hot chick I just don't want to
look at it because it feels like you're
too nervous you look a little bit but
it's good to know that the girls look at
the hot dude in the the curiosity stem
what time we're like Pervin out but
we're not proven Isis glad [ __ ]
surrounds like I'm not staring at you
but I notice I like sitting in the I
like practicing at the very back row I
hate that all the girls in the front
they get on doggy style and then it
makes me work harder like Joe it's
called Down Dog first our dog is doggy
style then I know it mo it's motivating
me to be more when you're in down dog
you only can look behind you you can't
look at me I like this as a strategy at
first but think it's so hot and crazy
you just can't you just now survival
it's like all the chicks move away like
I'm dying I'm so cold in regular life
that a hot yoga feels good it feels like
normal cuz you're filipino grab a
tropical blood cuz of when I'm in Bali
I'm like this is how it should always be
yeah so yeah she had to spend six weeks
after like it like basically couldn't do
anything for over two months I had
difficulty getting out of bed constant
headaches pain in her eyes when she was
around a bright environment but she lost
20 pounds
I was telling my friend I was like dude
I was like not going to yoga and he's
like what the [ __ ] you doing up for it
and I was like Indians yo how many
Indians have you seen in your yoga class
ever I'm like not a lot of Indians and
me and my yoga class is like yeah that's
what I'm saying
who does yoga in India because they're
doing it in their house huh
no he's just saying [ __ ] maybe rethink
my [ __ ] yeah I barely see any Indians
and EMI yo yo cousin you know what as a
know laka booka appropriating Indian
culture like humans around what like
it's just stretching its stretching and
I'm with it and I didn't at first I
thought yoga was the hardest thing ever
because I'm not flexible at all but I
realized that if you just like focus on
your breath like you're supposed to do
that's when the poses get easier but you
can't be thinking about anything else
right you have to just be focusing on
your breath they say yoga is like this
the whole physical is a secondary
attribute it's really just a meditation
for like our yeah but you know like have
you ever try to meditate and all these
thoughts go in your head I can't
meditate but when I do yoga I'm
completely in the moment because you
have this I don't believe in that
breathing [ __ ] have you ever had [ __ ]
Yoshi sadar so stretch you know no Shiva
Shiva is one of the worst feelings I've
ever experienced in my life who is bad
he's he's a stunt actor but that's how
you know you're stretching correctly
because if you're stretching correctly
you can only be in the moment but it's
so painful you can't think of anything
exactly and that's how Yoko feels friend
you're supposed to stretch yourself like
that yeah that [ __ ] has gone worse
feeling ya ever do and then you get a
stroke Raja now stretching stretched the
living [ __ ] out of me dude I screamed so
hard but does it feel good after no I
just don't feel it does does it stops
oh that's well that's different that's
like stabbing myself and then taking the
knife out it was like so good-looking
and stacked he's like stretchy like if I
do this I'm gonna look like
look at the mirror we look at our face
is it the same like David this is change
your face I was like what the [ __ ] am I
doing this for
so for three months all she could hear
was like whooshing sounds in her ear
because it was it was the sound of her
artery trying to get blood and say oh my
funny how like some people work out and
they still get cancer it's some crazy
[ __ ] like that happen some people smoke
and [ __ ] drink and healthy and they
live to are like 105 and [ __ ] well you
mean ironic it's ironic it's [ __ ] up
should be like not to be hurt
it's worse that you hurt yourself it's
funny because they it's like you're
working so hard for something and you
still get [ __ ] burnt for it that's
like when I gained weight after doing
crazy workouts because I'm so stressed
out about doing the workout right that I
gained weight from service que sera sera
who the [ __ ] can just live there's that
one Vietnamese dude [ __ ] smoke every
day he was building his own coffin he
was like a hundred and five years old
[ __ ] yeah I think those videos are
Chinese but he's like literally there's
a video that he's making his own comic
over a hundred years old
and he's smoking as he's building his
own cottage and I said oh and he's just
like wait he's like man I've been
building this coffin for 10 years and
their kids are like he smokes like a
pack of cigarettes every day hundreds
like you know I know for this is not an
alien correct be stuck he died yeah
one flew he's done I know so after six
months her and the doctors confirmed her
carotid artery is completely healed she
still does yoga but she's only at like
she feels like she'll never be a hundred
percent again so oh I wouldn't go upside
down anymore if I got a stroke like that
I just told her selling her button
spider legs like that again she just
says Sun Salutations that's what that is
no this window
she doesn't look good though she's
killing again yeah you know even a
hospital she look cool
[Music]
[Music]